[Music]
travel to almost any national park in
East Africa and you can see lions but
outside the parks these captivating
creatures are dwindling fast no one
knows that better than Lawrence Frank
who has studied Lions for more than 30
years the public even the conservation
world is not aware of this serious
trouble that these animals are in we
know a lot about how lions stalk their
prey on the open plains but how do they
hunt in the dense bush and it might when
they're most active
[Music]
for that bit of dangerous detective work
there's Crittercam an innovative camera
system created by national Geographics
Gregg Marshall that can ride along with
a lion
I think it's absolute madness to come
all the way to Africa to try it on a
lion which has got to be one of the
toughest tests of a piece of technology
you can imagine I'll be astounded if
this works
remember the Crittercam unit has to
withstand bounding speeds of more than
30 miles an hour
jarring leaps of 30 feet or more and the
violent collision of flesh that is a
lion kill
[Music]
the team tracks a lioness named Leila
she's already wearing a radio collar and
she may have developed a taste for
cattle
[Music]
back in the car so you get to top her up
I'm gonna give quite a substantial
top-up since we're gonna walk her down
for a long time
Lawrence gives Leila a full physical all
part of keeping tabs on the health of
this particular lion population then
comes the camera which is equipped to
send a lie signal back to the crew
another first or Crittercam
Oh oh my god the first shots are of
Layla's homecoming with the Cubs and
lionesses of her prize and the camera
withstands that gentle attention you
might now get the lion crunch test the
next day when the crew signals the
camera to transmit it's a family feast
[Music]
the second Crittercam
goes on a lioness named Haley the other
adult female in Leila spry
[Music]
and what appears that night on the
cruise monitors is the sight of two
lionesses hunting thanks to night vision
the crew captures a rare look at
teamwork between two big cats
[Music]
after more than a week of riding with
lions and it's time to retrieve the
equipment the Crittercam crew can
release the cameras by remote but
retrieving them takes a while the Cubs
are curious the first terrestrial
critter cam whether every fashioned bunk
Alliance gave it a zebra feast powers of
abuse in the bush and the dreaded cub
chew test and I never expected it to
work more than five minutes ended hung
in there for over a week this task is
Lawrence 1 or 2 when I see attempts to
learn more about how these large cats
can live with their human neighbors
wouldn't the world be an incredibly
impoverished place of there weren't
large predators world without wilderness
and wildness and personified by these
big predators simply wouldn't be worth
living in